[Music]
that's a bug
that is a lens flare that is a light
that's in the bottom of the frame
we think that's an alien
oh wait
i think whatever we're looking at
actually did happen
[Music]
aliens
are we alone in the universe
we need to answer that question today
we're going to look at some clips of
ufos aliens extraterrestrial sightings
and we
hopefully come out of this with that
answer we are visual effects artists by
trade we spent our entire lives trying
to make things look real now we've
trained our eyeballs to spot even the
most subtle fakeries there's a part of
me
i'm a skeptic but buried beneath that
skepticism
is hope hope that one day we'll see a
video clip with a real alien
hopefully that's today
[Music]
what are we looking at here this is a
clip from russia
ah
the effects
all right right off the bat we gotta
effects i guess you can only see ufos
through
small shattered pieces of acrylic
oh there's a fake blur
so to be clear what you're talking about
here is he's actually blurring the
entire shot as opposed to just blurring
out the ufo in time with the footage but
the footage wasn't blurred yeah he's
just blurring the entire shot this blur
looks to me like a box blur or a
gaussian blur which is something in
after effects
versus like a real camera lens blur so
the way a blur happens in real life is
you're basically you're passing light
through this point in the lens you know
it's trying to project a point onto the
the sensor or the film that you're using
and when things are out of focus that
light beam rather than like hitting that
exact spot from all these different
angles it starts to miss a little bit
you have what's called a circle of
confusion when things go out of focus we
should be feeling the shape of the
aperture a little bit in the blur but
instead it's a very even uniform blur
also the color isn't treated correctly
when the blur happens because it's not
real footage that we're that we're
seeing blurred from the camera blurring
it naturally what the way blur works is
basically the brighter parts of an image
will overtake the darker ones so the sky
is the brightest element in this and as
you look at the buildings defocus you'll
see that the dark parts on the buildings
are treated as
as bright as the sky is which isn't how
it would actually work so when you're
doing visual effects for a shot you want
to integrate real life phenomenon that
can overlap or blend your fake elements
with your real ones however in this case
i'm seeing tracking i can just see the
track is slipping just a little bit yeah
i saw that
i mean as a video i'm kind of digging it
it's got a creative little idea behind
it it's executed mostly pretty well but
this isn't convincing me that aliens are
real all right let's see the next one
lunar waves filmed at 200 frames per
second oh i can't wait okay wait hold up
pause five five
do people go out there just film the
moon for long stretches of time and then
come back into their house and watch the
video
hell yeah probably i take pictures of
the moon and then i zoom all the way in
and look at it and like just make sure
it's all there
oh there it is there it is what
yeah i see it but that's not like all
right assume everything's coming through
the lens okay well what is this a wave
orbiting a spherical object then why is
the distortion in 2d yeah instead of in
3d you know what i'm saying like why
aren't we seeing some sort of circular
effect that shows
like right now we're seeing a 2d wipe
but if it's
a wave going around a 3d object it's
going to have to come to a point and are
you saying that this telescope is
perfectly lined so that the wave looks
2d
what we're seeing here is
two-dimensional distortion yes i think
that's the big thing so forget what the
moon is all about forget who's on the
moon these waves are not happening on
the moon forget aliens for a second the
effect that we're seeing whether it's
vfx or
real it's happening between
the earth and the moon it says 200
frames per second they could be using a
crappy digital camera that has an issue
like you know you have like screen
tearing on your computer screen cameras
can do that too where they get out of
sync and like you're getting one frame
in the other frame and slowly a scan
line moves down through it it could be
just an effect in after effects that's a
displacement map in 2d
it's literally just a displacement map
which is going to basically distort and
move parts of the image based on like
another image like here apparently some
sort of gradient a black and white wave
file going across it and the effect is
using that to distort the image
underneath it
let's commend the person's
uh creativity
i mean this is very creative i would
have never expected
lunar waves
to be something so mysterious it's like
that is
that is new
what a concept
this is my second passion in life i
wanted to share this with my amazing
subscribers
i've been into ufo phenomenon since i
was in my teens my dad
rip
told me no no you guys say out loud
told me about the roswell crash in 1947
and that got me started on january 9th
2019 sam schwartek and jimmy chappie
released never
before seen footage of a ufo
hi
i'm getting project loon vibes right now
i'm excited all right and in five
four
three
two
one
aliens oh
that was a bug come on that's a bug
come on
that's a bug i've seen that before in my
own drone footage that's what the
what
they think that's an alien
they think that's an alien
what i was expecting like something in
the sky
that's so bug i've i'm not kidding i've
literally had that exact thing show up
in my own drone footage before and it's
because you literally almost hit a bug
but a show a bug this far away from a
tiny little lens is going to look
massive and fast the first frame where
you can clearly see the bug starting to
show up is probably just like five to
ten feet in front of the drone yeah and
the only other thing you can see in the
scene is probably like one or two
hundred feet away at least the bug
probably isn't actually moving that fast
the drone being so far away from
anything to give the perspective of how
fast it's moving is actually probably
moving in around like 30-ish 40 miles an
hour so a bug moving in the other
direction just barely missing the camera
lens
[Music]
will give the illusion that it's some
crazy fast thing it was actually like
the size of like a spaceship yeah you
would be leaving shockwaves and like
vapor trails like yeah the fastest any
sort of like piloted aircraft can go is
around mach 3 and like the space shuttle
coming in for landing i think that comes
in at somewhere around like seven or
eight once it starts slowing down
because air at high speeds is literally
molasses and so if that bug actually was
the size of a spaceship and that
mountain is like what three miles away
it'd have to be going like mach
15. i mean the air would light on fire
there's no way it's a spaceship at mach
15. i just i can't believe they
considered that to be a ufo yeah this is
not a ufo this is ufb maybe it's a you
know grasshopper we have no idea what
kind of bug it is yeah it could be an
alien bug
that's a good point sam it could be an
alien bug
sorry to all the people in the comments
of this video who are utterly convinced
this is a spacecraft
look okay i know it's important whether
or not aliens are real whether or not
footage of ufos
are in fact ufos or something
explainable but you know what's even
more important you know what is
explainable today's sponsor expressvpn
if you're not paying attention yet
there's a lot of things going on in the
world that might restrict your internet
access depending on where you are and
what you are trying to access this is
contradictory to a free and open
internet and it also leaves your data
vulnerable to hackers and being sold to
third parties and one way to protect
yourself and still get access to the
whole internet to every platform that
might be available and all the content
that is on those platforms is to use a
vpn you see the first thing that a vpn
does is it tells websites and apps on
the open internet that you are accessing
their sites from a different location
this allows you to access content on
platforms like netflix or to access
platforms in their entirety that you
might not have access to otherwise
that's not even the best thing it's
going to do for you the best thing it's
going to do for you is also provide you
that additional layer of encryption so
that you know your data is secure and
it's not going to be taken by a hacker
or by one of those dirty third-party
advertisers that you might find out on
the open internet we love expressvpn
because they have servers in over 94
countries they've been rated number one
by cnet and tech radar and i gotta say i
use them all the time to access
different netflix content from all over
the world and it's actually a great way
to expand what you have access to to
expand your creative horizons to just
give yourself that additional layer of
freedom that you might not have access
to currently there's a lot going on in
the world vpns are a great way to
protect yourself and to make sure that
you can have access to everything that's
out there so again if you're interested
in getting access to one we think
expressvpn is the way to go
if you want to get three months for free
you all you got to do is click the link
in the description below or go to
expressvpn.com
code or crew e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
corridor crew now that you know that
let's get back to the episode
all right what do we got hit me with the
yoho cotton camera in waltham style
literally you can see the strength it's
literally you can see it's a mylar
balloon with a string yeah some little
child was skipping along a sidewalk to
their birthday party and their balloon
flew into the air and now a dolphin's
going to eat it and die this is not
scary or mysterious this is tragic
all right next
[Music]
[Applause]
oh i know what that is that is a lens
flare that is a light that's in the
bottom of the frame that is as he's
panning during the inverse motion yeah
you're right once the light on that
apartment building centers up the light
will center up to you
comes right through right there in the
middle and then watch we'll do the exact
inverse motions as the apartment
building goes down the frame that lens
sort of goes up in the frame all right
well debunked
next
please watch it carefully
this is the video recorded by pedro
hernandez
oh my god what is this
with the birthing orbs the ship bursting
orbs
deploying the birthing the homes to the
planet
this is low quality
you know all these ufo enthusiasts are
not like doing a good like they're not
making a good case by uploading this
like horribly compressed footage that no
one can actually discern whether it's
real or fake oh wait hm oh there we go
now it's getting unexplainable initially
wasn't unexplainable interesting
that looks like a jet flame or like a
either afterburner or a rocket like it
looks like a missile
i've seen so many shots of missiles by
the way and they don't move like this
you're right another perspective is like
dark and it's moving differently i mean
could these be flares they don't really
move correctly for that
no this one's weird man i don't know
what this one is
the motion is really unique it would be
very hard to track the camera
simulation is like if this is vfx it's
like really good things go out of focus
correctly the exposure reacts correctly
the color space seems to work correctly
and like it's hyper compressed but
that's also doing a lot to help it as
well and make it look really real
so
i'm gonna rule this one
as a maybe
look we looked at everything else
critically and everything else is
clearly bugs or satellites this one is
nuts there's nothing in here that's like
it could be visual effects right it
still could be visual effects
alright time for some research
we have a second witness
with a video camera
recording the same event in the other
side
so this is supposedly recorded in mexico
city by two different people in 2009
so the question would be it's like are
these the same like 3d animation or like
are they the same thing are they the
same event or are they both filling two
different things
they seem to time up there this one's
interesting because one of the big
things with ufo footage is you would
have
other people filming it at the same time
like if a disc appeared over like los
angeles
we'd have millions of photos and videos
about it
so this is 2009 so cell phones aren't
super prominent yet but you have two
video sources of this they appear to
line up
however i was able to find the original
video and there's something just a
little bit suspicious in it
there's a crossfade there
oh my god that was atrociously
cross-faded
yeah and then he zooms back in it
cross-fades again cg it's completely cg
i don't know sam i think it's just a
little early for the do-it-yourself vfx
revolution that we're in right now
someone recreated a very similar style
video
[Music]
so yeah this is obviously fake but this
feels like this is like the same thing
we're looking at here this is almost
identical like the animation is almost
exactly the same yeah but it's not
zoomed in as much it's not like it's
clearly very much like very similar very
inspired but like the amount of
compositing and tracking and like camera
effects that have to go in
to the other shots would be very
difficult
when did this come out it was uploaded
to youtube august 18th of 2009. oh
[Laughter]
it was made in 2009 and it's credited to
a mexican vfx artist oh really oh wow
this could easily like
like the animation's identical it even
has the four things that get tethered to
it and like seem to pull it around what
else is on his youtube channel what else
is on this guy's youtube channel
there he is
oh i reckon i i recognize that face oh
oh weird that's funny where do we
recognize him from the ufo international
ufo conference
they're conspiring but the shot he made
came out after the sighting and it was
not as good oh it came out after oh well
of course if he made one of his his best
works he would never upload it to his
own channel a humble vfx artist stumbles
across the perfect ufo vfx shot of
course he won't post it on his own
channel because the evidence is there
that he's been faking it this whole time
no he conspires with someone
a man on the ground
to get him
some background plays some some footage
of the sky who else who does he contact
next the international ufo conference he
orchestrates
this entire i need to see the proof sam
i need to see the proof i don't think no
you know what no
no i don't think it's cgi there's like
eight minutes of that footage and it's
composited flawlessly
out of focus boca perfect the color
bleed perfect the noise perfect the zoom
the distortion it's all perfect it is
way too perfect i'm on niko's side here
i think whatever we're looking at
actually did happen yeah i think this is
real footage but i don't know what it
could have been
well
perhaps
my theory has a few flaws but
i think there's too many coincidences we
need to
infiltrate the international ufo
conference and figure out what they're
really trying to do
this could very well just be something
that's
normal and real or somebody you know
flying something or balloons or whatever
it's just it's filmed in such a way
that's like filtering it so hard it
makes it mysterious and that's what a
lot of ufo footage is it's really just
kind of normal things are being filmed
in such a way and they're so hard to
visually process that
it becomes unexplainable and that's what
this probably is could it be aliens sam
always always
project loon
what is project mode
i need to figure out the secrets of
project bloom
i heard you mentioned project loon
earlier do you have any updates
we've discovered the secrets of project
loon
on our crew cuts show we made a
follow-up to our last debunking video
where we went even further in depth to
discover the origins of project loon
that little dot in the sky well there's
a complete breakdown with gps and camera
tracking and positions and all that
stuff where we've mapped out everything
in complete detail of what actually was
going on in that shot cordovadigital.com
[Laughter]
randy did we see actual ufos today
i saw lots of ufos today all those
little orbs they were unidentified
flying objects i'm not saying they're
aliens i'm not saying they're not aliens
if you have any awesome ufo footage send
it to us debunk quarterdigital.com we
would love to take a look at it and see
if our trained illusionist eye for films
and videos can help figure out what
might be happening in these mysterious
clips that are shared with us so
see you guys in the next one thanks for
watching consider subscribing